good morning believe nation today's
messages keep moving forward over to you
Michelle Obama some of you have been
homeless some of you have risked the
rejection of your families to pursue
your education
many of you have lain awake at night
wondering how on earth you are going to
support your parents and your kids and
still pay tuition and many of you know
what it's like to live not just month to
month or day to day but meal to meal but
graduates let me tell you you you should
never ever be embarrassed by those
struggles
you should never view your challenges as
a disadvantage
instead it's important for you to
understand that your experience facing
and overcoming adversity is actually one
of your biggest advantages and I know
that because I've seen it myself not
just as a student working my way through
school but years later when I be after I
came before I came to the White House
and I worked as a Dean at a college in
that role I encountered students who had
every advantage their parents paid their
full tuition they lived in beautiful
campus dorms they had every material
possession a college kid could want cars
computers spending money but when some
of them got their first bad grade they
just fell apart they lost it because
they were ill-equipped to handle their
first encounter with disappointment or
falling short
but graduates as you all know life will
put many obstacles in your path that are
far worse than a bad grade you'll you'll
have unreasonable bosses and difficult
clients and patients you'll experience
illnesses and losses crises and setbacks
that will come out of nowhere and knock
you off your feet but unlike so many
other young people you have already
developed the resilience and the
maturity that you need to pick yourself
up and dust yourself off and keep moving
through the pain keep moving I think
this is a message that entrepreneurs can
relate to one of the things that we have
to do to be successful as an
entrepreneur is keep moving forward you
have to stay committed to your dream
even if you do things on the side just
to make money just to get by you need to
keep moving forward and never lose sight
of what you're trying to accomplish
because it's gonna get hard and a lot of
you guys watching this you know it like
you're living it right now this might be
a terrible day for you right now because
you're not achieving what you want to
achieve and I feel you I was the guy
making $300 a month in my business
struggling sucking having a lot of the
personal value that I had feeling of
self-worth just sucked out of me because
I wasn't feeling like I was adding value
to the world I was feeling like anything
I did was just failing and not working I
didn't know how to get out of the hole
so you're gonna get into the hole and
it's gonna happen multiple times on the
business side as well as on the on the
personal side you're gonna be in a
number of holes and here's the here's
the difference you have one or two
choices when you're down in the hole the
first one that a lot of people just end
up defaulting to is they blame and
complain they blame and complain you're
blaming your parents for not giving you
a better education or not being from a
better environment you blame the
president because the president's
policies you know really screwed over
your business you blame that customer
for not buying from you even though you
think that you had the best option and
you complained you complain about your
situation you complain about the lack of
money in your bank account you complain
about how you open your wall there's
nothing there you complain about how you
don't have any time you blame and
complain and blame and complain and as
long as you continue to blame and
complain you're gonna stay in that hole
where you are and where you deserve to
be and that
socks the path out the second option is
you take responsibility instead of
spending all that time playing with
other people and complaining about your
situation use that time and invest it
into making the situation better when
you realize that you're in this hole
because of you because you need to do
better because you need to add more
value because you need to be more
resourceful when you take on that
responsibility then things start to
happen then things start to change and
until you do if you just live in the
land of blame and complain you're never
gonna take action because always
somebody else's fault when you realize
that it's your fault
first that sucks that's a that's a low
but it's also a high in that you realize
that if you change if you add more if
you keep working you'll climb out or if
you don't accept that responsibility you
stay down in the hole and if you look at
successful entrepreneurs you look at the
people who've done from nothing and
built huge businesses look at how they
started most successful entrepreneurs
have gone on to build massive wealth
they started with less than what you
already have right now and quite often
they turn their businesses over to their
kids where you look at the entrepreneur
founder who had no education and no
money no resources and just managed to
build it out of sheer will when all the
odds were stacked against him built some
massive massively successful company
become massively wealthy and then they
want to hand it over to their kids and
their kids growing up with everything in
their favor with the education with the
money with the mentors with the
connection with a great environment
everything in their favor and they take
over the business and they run it down
into the ground because they blame and
they complain instead of accepting
responsibility for where they are and
being resourceful to climb out so when
you're down in the hole or maybe you're
there right now what are you gonna do
blame and complain or accept
responsibility so the question they
today is I'm curious what hole are you
climbing out of right now what hole are
you in that you're trying to rise up and
get to the top leaving the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Ryan Hicks from taught to profit Ryan
thank you so much for buying a copy of
my book it really means a lot to me
those are you watching you want a chance
at a shout out in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching having a
they continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
beso